I certainly want to follow up see how my
boy Brent and my boy ma'amed are doing
after the big IQ test I definitely want
to check in with them this morning
there he is are you exhausted from the
IQ test I mean all the discussion of it
yes from a show point of view
thank God you lost the IQ test because I
don't think one that could have handles
graciously as you did where is mom at
what did he do last night that's what
I'm wondering you know aren't you in a
way yeah sure you know and no one likes
to lose a competition my met how did you
celebrate or did you celebrate last
night it honestly wasn't as fun as I
thought it was gonna be to win I think
was more a relief for you
oh yeah and I felt horrible about it
yesterday I think I came off poorly and
like I said I didn't I I didn't like you
know I I didn't like Brent losing and
also Howard can I just say like I woke
up freaking one o'clock in the morning
last night in a panic I feel like I owe
you an apology
go ahead why I'll take it but I even got
it one o'clock in the morning and
grabbed a card to write you an apology
no or what because I was saying you know
I didn't trust you and that you were
rigging in I think you took that
personally and I didn't well I mean you
get on the air and you say we rigged the
whole thing I said that that that
questions my credibility do you accept
my apology for yesterday because I
absolutely bring me your note by the way
could you know I don't cry come on just
[ __ ] read it but if I cry am I gonna
be like banned no I just cuz you mean a
lot to me and I hate that I like hurt
your listening look at me look me in the
eye never mind these are the [ __ ]
guys yeah you did a great job thank you
you did good radio if you are you crying
I I get emotional with you like you know
what I'm saying
sorry you get emotional I feel bad look
at me when someone does good radio there
is no what's going on right now I'm like
I'm a little beige sometimes okay that's
when I talk about you man you know I
like this emotional side of you
see these guys let me tell you something
I've learned to cry in therapy I admire
your strength in showing your
vulnerability look at me I can't look at
me not running though I'm fine no stay
here don't run
I like the softer side of you read the
note Robin I'm having a moment with one
of my guys you know like a baby if he
raised it in it
I hear you know I'm working into it Gary
bring the med a tampon I mean it look at
me I want to say something emotional to
you I like your energy I like what you
put into the IQ test you let it all hang
out thank you you're look at me look at
me you did a great job I am NOT angry
with you I'm not upset with you I
applaud you now read me your note good
riddance we'll all be quiet Howard I I
feel I owe you an apology for saying ah
uh Howard I feel I owe you an apology
for saying on air that I thought the
contest was this is so stupid was fixed
I went home today feeling sick about it
in the heat of the moment in the studio
I was just trying to be funny it didn't
occur to me that I could be seen as
legitimately questioning
that's legitimately questioning your
integrity or the show's honesty I'd
never purposely disrespect you like that
you've damar too much for me I hope you
can understand and accept my deepest
most sincere apology I'm sorry all right
listen to me not only do I accept your
apology I love your apology read it
again it was yeah read it again slower